so Sam sat down one night and in a
flurry of fingers he typed up a GTA v
script and basically involves dudes
walking around and getting shot now we
are out in the road breaking Street laws
and city traffic laws in order to get
you guys the best video we can possibly
get you here with the pole so recently
we are shooting a longboarding video we
were doing it with a small gopro gimbal
basically attaching a little GoPro onto
the stabilizing electronic gimbal and
extending that out to get basically
crane shots the shots were so smooth and
they look really good and we were pretty
much able to do anything we wanted the
footage almost looked like
drone footage it looked like we could
follow anything and move it to any angle
or get any shot and I kind of realized
oh wait a second this is the perfect way
to film the GTA video Plus this and up
Jake will get out and we'll have him
like do something first maybe like take
out a gun like Cheech let's start
loading it up just we have a minute here
to like have them still and we can like
pass off the pole and basically from
there once it's in your hands
I'll be getting out as well I'm gonna
have to the door to deal with as well so
if you get like strafe sideways a little
bit so like I can just take the pole
from you and go sideways as well and we
originally think about taking this gopro
gimbal and sticking out the end of a PVC
pipe like we did for the mile video but
realize that for this one we need to get
something longer that wasn't quite as
heavy yes is that when you're filming a
car moving versus filming a person
moving you need a little more distance
for safety if the person driving taps
their brakes and you're that close
you're just going to run into them so we
needed something that could give us that
nice long safe distance so we hit up the
guys at K Tech they make some of the
best largest longest strongest
boom poles out there and they sent us
one of their their largest poles and we
used that as the base for our our boom
in this video we attached the GoPro on
the gimbal and then we taped the gimbal
and to the actual boom pole and from
there we were able to do everything with
it from just walking around getting
shots to shooting people on a bicycle to
sticking out of a sunroof and having it
extend over 20 feet out to film the car
in front of us
figured it'd be best to try and capture
a lot of those iconic places you see in
the game because if we're going to be
recreating it in real life it's a little
more than just getting action and angles
right it's about making the whole world
feel like it's in the game and you're on
our second day of filming for the GTA
video and we are here at beautiful
Vespucci beach to get some cool shots
for the intro and you're going to be in
a busy area you don't want to have a
huge camera big rig you want something
that looks like this something that just
looks strange but very unassuming
manages a really nimble gimbal like this
is the ability to be able to transfer
from different locations like the grass
here to the concrete how are they
filming is so smoothly and still getting
a really sweet shot all these different
environments where it's like they have
to do a shot on a drone didn't basically
GoPro shoots are the best they're low
impact you blend in no one bats an eye
when you have a GoPro in your hands so
you can go places like this super busy
places and shoot away don't care theater
so just look like a couple dudes having
fun under fancy toys
certain phone network yeah so visual
effects um um huh wait more we wait
better it's gonna look looks pretty good
right now
yeah but golden hour dude this is gold
now somehow so here we are at another
classic Los Angeles location the
Griffith Park observatory where Jake
will be selling money for drugs
fun fact our terrible criminal actually
has a law degree he's our lawyer
so we're filming here at Griffith
Observatory and we're trying to take
gta5 just illegal stuff and it's just a
super public area as you can see by all
the people and have a little awkward
trying to not draw attention meanwhile
we had Sam here carrying this crazy
GoPro contraption with a bone sticking
out of an umbilical cord riding an IO
mock sounded music but music first
because for this video we got to feature
one of my favorite electronic artists of
all time
carpenter brut we used the song paradise
warfare from his latest EP you can check
it out on Bamm camp the album is
incredible but in regards to the actual
sound effects for this video what we did
though we figured you know what we're
making a GTA video in real life but
let's just use sounds from the game
there weren't like sound packs used or
sound libraries or we didn't like hack
into the game and actually take the
sound effects Carmichael and myself work
together to basically go in the game and
actually recreate these moments in
similar locations so when the guy steals
a car that's the actual sound of
stealing car in the game in that
location when he's at the gun range and
shooting a gun that's the actual sound
of shooting a gun at the gun range so
trying to keep things one-to-one like
actually recreating these moments in the
game and capturing what that sounds like
so I really hope you guys enjoyed this
video this is a project we've been
wanting to do for a very long time if
you want to see cool videos like this I
highly recommend checking out our
patreon page or you guys can directly
support more videos like this they're
not easy to do they take a lot
time and energy from a lot of people and
your support would be greatly
appreciated so that being said I hope
you guys learned something from this if
you have any questions or comments leave
them on Twitter or send us an email or
leave them in the comments below we'll
try and answer as many as we possibly
can every single one Jake over here I
think I got it were you outside just
like waddling around running around the
neighbors are laughing at me you know
really